let's go baby i'm too wired like i just
want to grab something
grab i don't like it grab kyle i don't
want to grab kyle you saw what he did to
me push me on the door you need it you
need something to squeeze something you
need a squeezy thing for your hand like
i'm like i feel like i want you to do
that why are you dropping dude
yeah oh who told you to do that
two shots is dangerous huh i mean if you
if you never do anything i can drink two
shots of espresso and take a long time
but but i love the taste i love the
taste of what i was drinking there you
go and i'm [ __ ] up because no i don't
think i can handle this really you seem
all right i seem all right yeah are you
just
you're saying that to calm me down a
little bit you do look like you've been
pulled over and you're answering
questions yeah and uh yeah i'm nervous
i'm drunk right now okay
yeah you have a driver's license yeah uh
yeah i have i haven't heard about it you
decided to try it you were retired today
uh no it's just today we didn't sleep
great no no we didn't but i think it was
just
i've had a coffee at this spot before
what spot first of all this is blue jam
mark and i went to blue jam right after
but like i don't know what they did to
it today where i feel mark's french
press
i don't know if they did something to it
the french press is strong yeah oh yeah
did you have what you had for espresso
you had an espresso small it was an ice
cream mocha and i smoked and they they
give two shots
so i'm [ __ ] up i mean for me
that does nothing i wake up i do two
shots then i do another two shots his
drink at the gym eight shots of espresso
eight shots that's a lot of it but
that's a big thing that's confusing just
to get me through the workout yeah stop
get another coffee on the way here and
then this is my third of the day
what is this is that's the groundwork
yeah oh it's that nitro this has all the
caffeine in it my my adrenal glands and
i have the shop and i was fighting like
they told me they're like dude they just
do a stimulus you just soak them in yeah
[ __ ] all the time like nothing gets to
them yeah you know what else and you and
i are junkies because we're just looking
for a little a little euphoric that
we're chasing that caffeine dragon and
that's all i've been doing my whole you
know what i did though dude is on uh
friday between the shows i was like
because i didn't sleep at all thursday
and i had trouble sleeping so i was like
man and jay's like why don't you get a
red bull i'm like yeah i like red bull
that won't affect me too much because i
drink so much coffee i drink a
sugar-free red bull
show is fine heart going
fluttering we get back we back to the
airbnb everyone all right guys go to bed
it's one the more i'm like cool laying
in bed i'm so exhausted and you know
when you just can't sleep i'm staring at
the wall my heart just
no 5 45 a.m
finally fall finally fall asleep mile
thank god because i don't have to do
anything today thank god
5 45 am i look at clock start to pass
out 6 am on the clock
i'm like wait what in the [ __ ] a rooster
i'm like holy every morning brian every
morning we're in a suburb in a regular
neighborhood you don't have to have
[ __ ] but you're not allowed to have
chickens that's why they zoned [ __ ]
foul it was insane like every [ __ ]
morning what are the what are these
zoning laws for foul and how insane is
that
insane the neighborhood the neighborhood
seems fine with it
it sounded old as [ __ ]
but loud here's the thing so that so
here's the thing so you know i i i was
like why the [ __ ]
would uh red bull [ __ ] me up and me and
jay looked it up and a lot of people
have this problem because it's synthetic
caffeine it's not real caffeine and
there's taurine in it your body
metabolizes it differently so my body's
like what is this it's new it was new oh
my god what is that what does that mean
my guess is you may have been next to
some [ __ ] fighting rings because if you
got roosters
doesn't nobody's laying eggs why are you
breeding roosters bro oh you're [ __ ]
fighting okay that's what it is big
money oh yeah up there
daddy would have bet on it oh yeah it
did let me in though oh yeah they put uh
razors on there and they yeah they go
you never seen that and they they
sharpen their claws and they it's really
money bro i thought that was just like a
foreign thing you got a hole in your
yeah yeah i'm just like that you know
yeah you should if you would like
don't lift your arms no more
i know you're entire that's not a hole
entire armpit is
dude
i had the sweater for a minute
for a minute i found i was like you know
you're like i'll wear this today
anyway thank you so that so that rooster
allowed us to get zero sleep and did it
keep going oh yeah we woke up early
every day so every morning i was up at
six no matter what time i went to bed so
i'm exhausted so my girl is like hey
what time do you land i'm like i land at
10. she's like okay tiger's uh best
friend's birthday party is at 11. i'm
like [ __ ] yeah
so i dude i'm so like i'm mean i was
driving i'm like i'm driving like
you drove back you drove to san jose no
no from the airport from burbank sure so
i'm driving dropped kyle off and i'm so
tired and i'm like oh my god i got four
hours their kids birthday party and i
remember a friend of mine gave me
admiral a long time ago and daddy has it
in his little sock drawer okay and how
much did you take cause i was just
before you said no
i don't know anything i took 10
milligrams and i i was wired i was on
cocaine 10 right
this will focus
i had some reading to do sure yeah not
for me i'm texting and listening to
music like like a [ __ ] method
10's average right yeah i wanted to
clean the plane yeah i wanted to clean
the window 10 you're gonna get your
master's degree in two days online yeah
dude here's my thing yeah i don't know
drugs how many pills you take one pill
but i noticed there was like a little
div in it so you could break it in two
i'm like i'm a big dude
50 milligrams there oh you got the 50
minutes dude this kid's birthday party
as [ __ ] dude
hey one dad was like hey man i'm like
hey how are you doing dude i was things
are great too you're a part of this [ __ ]
right what the thing is they had my
favorite pizza there even on my keto i
was like i'm going to push it today of
course you don't need on adroll my girl
goes why aren't you eating it inaudible
and then draw
yeah just clinch the whole swallowing
the whole time well it's coke oh but
yeah it's amphetamine oh it was that
kid's five-year-old party and he's
supposed to be the life of the party
yeah your boy's life for the party
because i couldn't stop dude
four-hour energy i call that [ __ ]
pill
anything's possible anything's possible
anything's possible for about five days
you're not creating amazing you're not
you're just you're not no you're not you
can't be crazy
you're talking a million miles an hour
and someone would be like
man the weather today like did you say
weather and then you just [ __ ] yeah and
there's no clean weather story oh dude
you go yeah yeah until 10 milligrams
[ __ ] my girl's like you're not eating
and she's like i don't think i've ever
seen you talk to these dads this much in
my life i was like just happy to be here
man and she's like what's wrong with
your jaw because i'm saying happy
birthday is all
right because i was coming down you know
oh dude and then you crashed then you
cuck a crap you must have you must have
slept
hard last night yeah yeah the big man
went down but uh but when i do do that
sometimes i wake up at like two in the
morning [ __ ] with my sleep cycle but i
took so much cbd that i just conked
myself out so you're going you're you're
doing you're encountering were you
trying to counteract we're roller
coaster in all day we got we got nickels
just yesterday because well we got we
got typically on a day we've got at
least 25 espressos we got some kratom
going we got some nicotine going no and
then we got and then then let's throw in
some adderall and then let's go very
rare right but then let's go kid's
birthday party six hours doggy yeah i
get a basic podcast with these [ __ ]
dads for six hours around the pool in
the sun
if you're not making me laugh making me
money or i'm not learning something
you're not interested i'm a dead man
right now i'm too old i'm too old i
can't just hang say something intriguing
now that that's a tough one because
you're around the pool the sun their
thing the sun
those birthday parties can be hey excuse
me i have fun with them but yeah i'll
find one guy
oh i might well yeah my boy toby he's
he's like me he's he's great he's the
one guy every time i'm going like okay
you going to this thing like yeah i'm
like thank god yep because other dads
are just swords
my my yep my friends soy boys my son's
10 year old birthday they were massed up
outside they were no they weren't i
promise and they go you're going to take
your mask
what i'm outside uh-huh but then you
know i think it was adderall made me way
more fair i went uh
why do you wear yours when you use your
unit kind of roast them yeah
you know you're such a good mood when
you're on that stuff oh man 50
milligrams i i'd probably start a
business dude by 9 pm though i was like
oh yeah oh yeah i'd be [ __ ] terrified
because i'm terrified right now for this
cause
yes
that's not like you gotta start living
dude those parties those parties what
happens is for me
i see it it's my son's ten tenth
birthday party a bunch i don't know the
parents recent or no yep i don't know
the parents
i gravitated to one dude he just seems
cool i lock onto one guy and you know
what turned out he was a fireman oh it
was like makes sense i always lock onto
one guy yeah just one dude and when he
leaves i'm like [ __ ] yes
then it's a wrap ben's problem the sky's
more adderall and then and then and then
everybody's my friend you want to snort
tomorrow does it go in your body faster
okay dude well because i want to stay
awake and be positive
and now i get why kids in college take
it like you know stay up [ __ ]
meatball over there [ __ ] snorts it up
his ass you do you do meatballs
for real yeah yeah
there's no description for it yeah so
you take you take the pill and stick it
with a thumb you you you you digit it
right up your [ __ ] yeah how far up
pretty far like sometimes i get like you
know like a little dust buster i'll put
on reverse and i'll put like the little
knuckle deep no but for reals you you
take like i do i do milligrams i thought
this [ __ ] was serious no no oh
you don't put it in your ass no oh no
it does absorb fast yeah doesn't it like
if you put something like a pill like
this
i had a friend who now he's an alcoholic
and ran uh drug trafficking for the
cartel makes sense he's in prison now
yeah but he was our college roommate and
he was a raging alcoholic and he would
put whiskey shots up his ass
and he got so common practice like oh
there he goes drinking whiskey through
his ass that's so [ __ ] hard that's
insane i know there's a guy my buddy
it's so dangerous because there's no
filter it doesn't go through the liver
the straight juice jimmy jimmy brooke
our buddy his his buddy he had let his
buddy stay with him from ireland for a
month well his buddy would do a coffee
enema every [ __ ] morning stick a tube
up his [ __ ] and be in the bathtub and
jim was like you know this is my
apartment
and you just do coffee yeah it's like a
dark one it's not good man [ __ ] is that
like a light blonde or whatever
like you think i have problem that's
another love that's weird [ __ ] man yeah
that can't be safe jimmy's like
dude that guy's putting coffee grinds up
his ass and jacking off in his tub well
yeah dude adderall is a big time it's
very abused right is it narcotic
everybody does it i was in [ __ ] um
indiana and a guy goes
and gave me adderall like i'm like i'm
the nicest did you take it i'm not gonna
trust no i didn't yeah well yeah what
yeah
but uh meatball you have a prescription
for it yeah so i have a prescription for
vivants which is 50 milligram um
extended it's time
to take one and a half technology you've
been taking this since you were a kid
like i don't i don't take it all the
time like i'll take it like three times
a week usually i have those and then i
have 20s what's the reason why they
prescribe you to it i have 80d yeah yeah
don't we all hey so
i mean that's what i always told you
yeah yeah me too everything has you mean
lots of energy and board is [ __ ]
school we all have him
don't take it when i don't take it i'm
tired
because you're used to it
yeah no no i i i don't need it anymore
you're a drug addict
and be honest and it's okay because
you're nobody's listening and also
you're in our in a circle of trust
do you ever take four vive ants at the
same time
oh no because you can time release you
can't od on it unless you take see no
i'll take it because what happens is
it's a time release thing right so like
every 15 minutes
it'll pop five milligrams
but a lot of people have coffee like
this right but a lot of people want to
get that big rush so they'll take a lot
of five vans
what do you mean they're big rush
this guy i feel like i have a big
restaurant i've never heard of these but
meatball what's up daddy
yeah teeth are chattering oh weird but
hey but meatball when you take uh ad
roll the next day are you like mean
or like because there's a down right so
during my calm down i'm more me not like
usually the next day when i'm because
like you said you don't eat on it so i
can tell i'm starting to come down
because i'll start to be hungry but like
i'll try and eat okay and i can't eat
and i'll be aggravated by it so i'll
just and i'll go and know it's like
someone's like hey what's up man i'll be
shut the [ __ ] up like i'll just be very
agitatable let's just go over adderall
real quick first of all let's do it
insane energy fantastic yeah you don't
want to eat on it so you lose weight get
shredded i'm sorry yeah why aren't we
pushing this stuff more i use it every
time i go to the gym it's the best well
because it is a strong narcotic and it
is isn't it isn't it like a cousin of
meth well it's an amphetamine salt yeah
so i guess it's uh yeah use it to go to
the gym yeah i'll take one instead of
pre-workout
well i'll take one of those and then
i'll go drink the pre-workout drink or
like a bang or something are you not jab
yeah because i don't i've been he's he's
pretty muscular i'm just he's he looks
good he's just doing 100 milligrams of
outer on a red line you should be
[ __ ] i'm you take a red line no
like dang c4 like those i haven't done
red wine but like i i have a problem
eating that's why [ __ ] crazy energy
drink is it the craziest one yeah huh is
it red line the craziest one i haven't
it's so dangerous i think they should
put ephedra in it look it up gin they
change it now but me and jay drunk one
in cobb one time and i thought i was
gonna have a heart attack have you ever
had the celsius heat no i don't get down
with that [ __ ] dude what's that i draw
the line at adderall it's it's uh
celsius the energy drink like it's a
healthy energy drink but they have a
heat warner yeah i took i drank one
during my workout because like i got one
late so i was drinking it while i was
working out
i come home
and it's
like you i was so [ __ ] up i was like
about to put my head in the wall i had
to go on like a [ __ ] three-mile run
yeah because i was like so like wound up
at the end of the day your adrenals your
heart i don't know i mean it's not good
for you
wait is it for loco an energy drink with
alcohol yeah no it wasn't bad yeah those
those are bad oh they're banned they
brought them back but with their
their soy boy i had one and my [ __ ]
chest was hurting from it yeah you'd be
careful man yeah dude definitely yeah
did you don't [ __ ] with anything like
that energy drinks no
adderall no i tried it you didn't like
you don't like drink coffee i drink
coffee sometimes in the morning
one thing
that i pride myself on is i'm a hard
sleeper but has to be the right mattress
i stay in air and bees all the time when
i'm on the road and they don't have my
mattress they don't have a helix sleep
mattress and i don't sleep as good i
just don't i like to wake up rested and
refreshed and sometimes when it's not
helix sleep that's not the case so when
i get home the thing i appreciate most
besides my kids is my mattress all right
if you need the best mattress
that's made just for your body get helix
sleep helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete it matches
your thick ass body type and your sleep
preferences with the perfect mattress
built for you not just for any joe
schmoe built for you and the way you
sleep all right i took the helix sleep
quiz and i was matched with a great
mattress that's built for me man it's
firm i like to sleep on my side and i
move around and so it takes care of all
that man the mattress is built for those
demands so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you're the
mattress that you're matched to the
mattress comes right to your door ship
for free you don't ever need to go to
match store ever again just go to
helixleep.com fighter take the two
minute sleep quiz like i did the match
you with a customized mattress that will
give you your best sleep ever 10 year
warranty gets trapped for 100 nights
risk-free if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for you but you're well so
don't worry about it helix even has
financing options available flexible
payment plans so a great night sleep is
never far away
again you can save 200 off all mattress
orders at helix sleep.com fighter you
also get two free pillows that's for the
viewers and listeners of the fire and
the kid helix sleep.com fighter
football's back y'all the first sunday
nfl season is finally done it doesn't
stop though it continues with draftking
sportsbook the official sports band
partner of the nfl and ufc drafts kings
is giving all new customers a can't miss
offer to celebrate the return of the nfl
season bet just one dollar on any week
two game and receive two hundred dollars
in free bets instantly no matter what
that's right draftking sportsbook is
giving all new customers 200 in free
bets instantly when they bet at least
one dollar on any week 2 football game
draftkings is safe secure reliable
making it easy to deposit withdraw your
money when you want download draftking's
sportsbook app now use promo code
fighter receive 200 in free bets when
you place a one dollar bet on any week
two game that's promo code fighter get
your free two hundred dollars in free
bets instantly this week at draftking
sportsbook and official sports band
partner of the nfl must be 21 or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only restrictions supplies see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 1800 gambler or in
indiana 1 809 with it
sometimes
just like a little black coffee yeah
i've never seen chin with a ton of
energy
[Laughter]
right i don't bounce off the wall you're
gonna be like god
i'm not yet
wired up bouncing off the wall
yeah
that's why i'm freaking out right now
yeah he's like
chill's better yeah chin's the cal
ripken of podcast producers yes you're
always a three
yeah
you get to the hall of fame
yeah but i'll just chill i'm trying to
be like barry bonds and juice and hit
the [ __ ] ball out the goddamn scott
yes i like that you you are a fan of
technology and you're a fan of whatever
gives you an edge sure and you push
yourself and you just want to get a
little you know but you know you're also
an addict and that's okay correct
you're an extremist you like your car
starts vaping
yeah yeah he is raping yeah i don't
inhale it though okay we went to a full
game you still get high yeah
yeah i got a pretty cool one i gotta get
you uh oh dude
yeah vitor beat the f i know
i know that [ __ ]
who let somebody's grandpa fight what
dude he threw down a hook i was like oh
my god this is one of the greatest yeah
he just slipped and fell through the
road throwing a hook i'm like i thought
about that you're one of the greatest of
all time and father time father time
comes in and goes you are an old man now
there's a reason for it though that's
right and everyone's like but with trt
and technology dude it does 60 boxing
isn't for 60 euros against vitor belfort
who's 44 but still
still a hell of an athlete yeah you know
what i'd like to say you know what i'm
going to say you know what i'm going to
say vitor logan paul jake now not jake
not logan jake yeah that'd be a good
fight huh
yeah that'd be a hell of a fight tough
fight for jake very tough fight for jake
it's it's tough to tell that's a
different thing right but it's tough to
tell where vitor is at like
[Laughter]
event with them and i was like oh my god
how's this guy putting he's got stirred
by florida look at that oh gosh that's
awful poor guy that is awful
it's just not right man
oh jesus christ
jack i know
he looks great
oh no i don't like this at all
i don't like this man i don't like
seeing one of the greats
oh geez see but those aren't even like
crazy shots either
then the guy just had to oh yeah dj
khaled had to stop it and how about
evander holyfield was mad at the
stoppage well he's gotta should have
been stopped six weeks ago
six weeks ago you shouldn't have been
allowed
should have been stopped six weeks
it was tough to watch huh yeah yes
didn't you see your boy tito yeah that
was tough to watch what was weird is in
the
derrick bronson bike tito derek's on
food truck tomorrow by the way but uh
what's inside about that is we were
watching officer watch in the back and i
was like oh is this like a gentleman's
agreement because he was kind of like
half ass in it and then we at the angle
you couldn't really see anderson landed
flush and then we see like oh that is
not gentleman's agreement that was a
hard
shot
yeah and i think tito wants fight logan
now is what he said so we're both coming
off losses
yeah i i don't like it i told you this
i'm below the belt i've been a fan of
like this cross-pollination of youtubers
celebrities and fighting like do what
you want if you're if you're making
money more power to you the guys who are
fighting these youtubers getting their
highest paydays of all time i'm all for
it this is the when i not tito and
anderson that's whatever
that makes sense when the first time
i've been like oh oh we've gone too far
is when a vanner got in there yeah and
fell through the left hook at 60 i'm
like well what are we doing man
dangerous now it's just not that's
dangerous it ruins his legacy it's like
what are we doing i also i'm as a huge
fan of of tito's
um and somebody who did so much for the
sport i don't want to see him get hurt
that's so bad for him and his age
that is so bad for him and 46 40 40 too
old because it's not just 44. you're
talking about a guy who's pushed his
body to such a limit yeah and fought so
much that when you take that kind of
damage and and you know i don't know how
hard that shot was it looked really hard
but the one thing that that it seemed
seems to be happening a lot of guys is
that when you when you take enough
damage to the head because you got to
remember he's training probably with
boxers yeah you're getting into the
full-on your body was shut down earlier
i just hate seeing you you're talking
about the toughest dudes
i hate seeing it yeah because i i don't
like seeing a great warrior like tito
put in there anderson silva still got a
[ __ ] load of punch left that dude stud
one of the greatest strikers yeah well
one of them's passionate about boxing
and then you guys do it for a payday and
that's what happens there you go it was
tough that was a tough card to watch man
i don't think jake paul is is is gonna
wanna like i think if they start
floating anderson silva's name out there
well logan and aniston were pretty close
to fighting before logan fought floyd be
a long that'd be a short night for for
logan i believe all due respect yeah it
would be tough that's i i don't i would
be very surprised if logan would take
that fight do you think he would take
that from he was going to
did he get talked out of it
uh no you got talked into floyd
mayweather for a 2 gillion dollars there
you go smaller much smaller guy yeah but
also a much bigger fight anderson is
every bit as tall yeah but anderson
versus logan's like you make that money
it does well anything logan does does
very well and anderson does well but not
floyd well that's right you can make all
the money fighting a small guy yes and
not stupid not get hurt and i can get
knocked out like we saw you know last
the rounds yeah anderson
did you go to any of the wing places me
and my brother recommended i did not go
to any of the wing places let me explain
why i go to buffalo dude now hold on i
know oh [ __ ] hold on now i don't care
about wings you understand because wings
are wings i know they're better in
buffalo but it's an american thing but
they're not you don't give a [ __ ] no
it's just it's just wings though i mean
there are different ways i've had good
wings you know you can salt and pepper
them or you can put buffalo hot sauce i
don't give a [ __ ] well you've never had
real ones yeah i have you never had
about magic
chicken you can't
this annoys me when people do this
because i can't say what the best pizza
is no it's not i know where it is and
also buffalo wings i don't care i mean
you didn't try chicken you didn't try it
and i did i didn't try them on purpose
oh well you're well now
you know that's why you pissed buffalo
people off i know i love buffalo no
because you came in here
and that was a [ __ ] town no i did not
say that in fact
i [ __ ] hate the pills
hey
you're trying to turn buffalo against me
with lies yeah no i didn't i like but i
loved buffalo and i love the people and
it's ten minutes away from canada which
i didn't know by the way
well it's ten minutes away from canada
so i was like you guys are drove to
niagara falls canada yeah they're so
nice the people are so [ __ ] nice
mm-hmm they're great people oh and the
crowds are they're just great they come
never go backwards you have great shows
yeah yeah you'll never be back well it
takes so long to get there
i found a flight of toronto correct
but i did find you find your places i
found my place graylin
and walking this into my my hotel
graylin is a gin bar
it's a classy gin bar with great
cocktails that they mix and i just sat
at that thing and i drank that was your
world i had some cocktails and you know
what i'm interested in drinking i'm into
a morrow i don't drink but i like
something like i like to taste it which
is that liqueur that italian herbal
liquid like campari is it campari it's
not comparable but you'd like of course
yeah well they made a lot of drinks with
comparisons
the cool thing about the internet is it
shrunk the world and you can get the
best of la and the best of new york in
buffalo if you know where to look
that that [ __ ] is my that's my drink
right now amaro uh what is italian it's
just like a syrup bittersweet yeah i
like the better [ __ ] good man not a
lot alcohol 16 no
no it's not but
i was a gentleman i was just sat there
and drank yeah everybody's really cool
it doesn't really match the wing vibe
you didn't do buffalo right now now i
went in i watched the tampa bay dallas
game because i'm a big dallas fan now
because i watch hard knocks
that
that's what happens with me that's what
happens with me don't let me see you
know i started rooting for nothing does
it the the countdowns on showtime have
you
your favorite box some random mexican
food yeah yeah like yeah i like him
don't tell me a backstory because all of
a sudden i'm a fan and that's why they
do those shows the countdown
that's why they do it now i'm all in
with the buffalo i put the [ __ ] with
the dallas cowboys
my dad are watching like dude i think
this guy's a shot against canelo you
know he grew up without a
mom dad i know you got really into the
show
please don't buy that kid's shirt yeah
because he's gonna get starched
now i'll tell you now
having said that as a as a dallas cowboy
fan and a dak prescott fan who's a great
quarterback uh great in what terms
he looks like he never won
we got injured but it doesn't matter
before that he's never won
you're going off backwards they're going
to make a couple i'm going to make two
tom brady would be considered great he's
great
did you see his face when they had a
minute 20 left yes he dude yes
yes he was holy [ __ ] he was [ __ ] he's
pissed he felt disrespected because they
scored so fast and gave him a minute and
20 like oh my god dude me and my brother
watching i go talking about [ __ ]
savage dude he's just like this he's
like minute 20
you
you can give me a minute 20. holy you've
disrespected me
don't be surprised if they win the super
bowl oh no for sure it's the same yeah
exactly antonio brown you got all those
guys you got i think gronk is there i
mean now you know you watch one episode
of first date and you're talking
football and i don't like it and i don't
like it no i know i know i know you
don't like it i've been inside tampa bay
i got tampa i got tampa i might become a
tampa fan if they start winning what do
you mean there's super bowl chance i
know a chance and it's also tom brady
how about that patriots lost this
weekend
i'm keeping my eye on belichick too
because i want to see what he can do mac
jones is pretty good for his debut
better than the rest of those rookies
um
he's your team meatball you're the only
one who looks for patriots uh patriots
and boxer mack jones look good i i
couldn't even watch the game we didn't
have because our nfl package wasn't
working no weird yeah
so we watched the the uh the rams game
rams looked tough yeah right it was a
really good game
dude that was a good one my broncos [ __ ]
all up on
giants i'll tell you what the bill's oh
who is that that's his girlfriend who's
not thankful so you don't become
stronger alabama even though he looks
pretty
average but you're going to get a dime
you know what i'm talking about
he's throwing touchdowns for the crimson
tide you think you're going to work
you feel me i mean they're girls these
girls are going to feel you're going to
want to breed with you let's put it that
way yeah even though you know it looks
like you know speaking of reading
my show my last show in in
buffalo
there was a group a family there and the
lady this this large family and the
ladies on large mean there's a lot of
them or a heavyset heavyset a lot of
them uh not so heavyset in fact two of
the girls three of the girls were such
smoke shows and i thought they were from
they looked like they were from ethiopia
so i said where are you guys from
they're like seattle or you know i'm
from this uh virginia and i was like oh
okay
yeah way off but they looked exotic they
were gorgeous okay
these beautiful black girls coming up
yeah
and then they love you and then turns
out turns out they want to get a casino
i think they love you brothers
an actress i guess so i was there
brought her family now here's the thing
the mother there the mother
she had three sons
and two play on the steelers and one
place for the bills and i went what's
their names i don't know i didn't get
the names one is running back the other
was middle linebacker and the other
one's a safety type in brothers
pittsburgh steelers yeah and i went
wow
i would like to have a child with you if
you don't mind because i want to know
what's going on this is clearly john
jones mom has the same kind of thing
this was clearly a white family it was a
very light thing this is a jewish they
were white and jewish and very small no
not watts it's definitely the watson
didn't come by the water
wait you said one's on the bills and
one's on the steelers right yeah see if
that's them that might be the ones
um that's why them unless there's three
others exactly who it is that's exactly
what it is and i met their mom
and uh classy good family tight family
you could see it i mean you mentioned
there and their girlfriends were the
beautiful women that were there it makes
sense i was like oh well of course
all you know one studs yeah
did anything happen
not a thing dude that was the story but
i just thought to myself mom what are
the chances of because you know how hard
it is to make what are the chances of
having three children insane you know
what i mean and you get three starters
in the nfl come on it's like well the
watt brothers think so not only
they're not not only starters one is one
of the best defense players of all time
yes two or three time defense play a
year his little brother should have won
it last year he's the captain of the pit
stud he's better i mean he's the guy now
what position tim bosa they're dns
they're freaks so they're all giants
yeah another brother's a fullback can
you bring home jj watts parents so i can
see what's going on there
that's just you know
that's nuts
connie
what oh the oh the dad is uh those are
the brothers damn look at them
those brothers are the dad is john candy
dad's dad's got yeah on him he hasn't
been missing any meals but mom
where are they from mom's got it by the
way mom's got a strong job mama's mama's
not weak mama's very strong uh-huh
yeah look at it now now without a dime
she's very pretty but also just for a
second it's important jj watts got a big
head mom's head is not that much much
she's got big bones look at that but
daddy's got a big head with it where
he's no top top yeah
well dad is every bit of what six four
probably yeah because what how tall is
jj what is six five six five yeah and
he's yeah that's 300 pounds yeah dad's
uh dad dad needs to wear a mask ground
down well then yeah dad that's what i'm
saying like dad better not get coco
dad's diet is what it is but but he's
clearly got something under there big
[ __ ] look at their look at the
brothers
they're all three playing together the
one on the the left next to the big dad
the one on the left place for the
steelers
super stud
what position
and then jj watt obviously won the best
of all time yeah and then the guy on the
right if you're gonna you know
he's the worst out of three okay but
he's still in the nfl he's still in the
nfl who's gonna play for uh i think
steelers so they're both on the steelers
that's why they thought jj was gonna
come to the play with his brother jj is
bigger than all of them oh yeah beat the
[ __ ] out everybody jj's with the
cardinals look at mom's wrists look at
mom's wrists and look at mom's arms mom
is a and she's not heavy she's she's put
together but she is a st
the genetics are coming from mom mom is
strong dad's enormous dude
that is a big boy god those are some
daddy jeans
those are some daddy jeans
he's just living life man dad's doing
he's not dad's doing what he wants
whatever the [ __ ] you want yes
but but uh that's crazy those are some
crazy genetics oh wow crazy genetics
yeah they're just big kids
what
what
what
what it's just you oh we have to do that
what
because i know what you're doing you go
wow
whenever you go oh wow
there's a point of view that's all and i
know what you're thinking and i know
what you're looking at yeah it's great
though man yeah they all made it they're
beautiful
i mean that is
yeah they're cool man
jay didn't play football did he uh in
high school he's too he's like in the
drugs and like running with the wrong
crowd i don't know what he does though
oh so crazy genetics
mom is that's uh whatever's going on
well there's a weird thing and then i
felt now it's like i forget like one in
three all have some connection family
member in professional sports yeah like
one in three one and two it's something
nice yeah that makes sense yeah i'm
sorry it's just you know you're either
built a certain way what it is man yeah
you know
speed and size now did you guys
illegally stream the trailer fights
no i didn't even have to do that
actually i just i could watch it on
twitter
i watched on twitter
you watched a feed on twitter no i mean
i just watched the highlight of them oh
you didn't see the phone they lasted a
minute a minute yeah so that's what you
can see yeah but did you see trump's uh
commentating i didn't pretty funny i
didn't it was called ashton silva
anderson silver
there you go
it's like i've known these guys for a
while i'm a huge fan anderson silver
you know okay he's amazing all right
dude he's amazing his son didn't really
say hi just go of course you said silver
yeah of course you do the rest of his
commentators whatever
yeah i mean
it was a trump rally though it was oh
yeah yeah they were screaming for trump
2020 2024 so is every ncaa arena
like every game just [ __ ] joe biden i
mean every single arena i know yeah i
know college kids are like [ __ ] jokes
they're hilarious
is that in uh certain that's in certain
states every state is in every state
well football you're gonna have some
group you know groups that come out
football fans are football fans american
they're americans they tend to be
heavily american oh yeah and then when
you when you leave a bunch of americans
it's nice it gets a little dicey people
get a little mad
dude i don't think new swims can get
recalled i know the gap is whining i've
been following it and they they tried to
do one last hail mary and i guess uh
newsome's wife has ties to harvey
weinstein
and she called that uh rose mcgowan you
know who's like the main girl yeah
called her to try to like intimidate her
well she tried i think they tried to get
her to drop the idea was to what would
it take how much money do you want to
drop because they're close to the
weinsteins yeah
that was the last hurrah
yeah i think i think we find out
tomorrow the official
the larger problem is that
he's only in but here's the thing he's
not in that much longer right he only
has another what eight months left i i
no i think he's got a longer than that
maybe not no more than a year but he uh
the real the real issue is how many
businesses have to leave california
before you know
it's a tough place in the business so
ends the 14th
i think it's on the 14th right
what's today
today's the 13th yeah yeah you kind of
crept up up there
why do they did you read why um was it
just
people didn't really want larry elder
yeah it's a democratic statement
yeah well what are you gonna do
um
yeah
now that he's not getting recalled
you know and the winner's coming coach
when just picks up
it's gonna be like lock back down
everybody yeah that would make me leave
that'd be the one thing yeah i think
maybe he's learned his lesson though
locking it and ruin all these small
businesses i think he's learned his
lesson that we can't do that again well
yeah i mean you know
if they keep pushing businesses to the
brink like that it's just gonna be
nothing left yeah yeah you know
i mean they did have a tax
surplus so they they
they do have a lot of money in the
coffers but yeah
california is a very very diverse
economy so you can get away with a lot i
know
you know you can get you can get away
with a [ __ ] load
you can get scared like it's like what
we always talk about like
whatever you think is going on like like
uh people hate them you gotta look at
the large macro perspective they might
hate him but they really hate
republicans
yeah they might hate him they despise
larry elder yeah or or for example if
you're picking two poisons they don't
want california to lose the seat in the
senate and all that stuff you know like
there's so much that goes on if he comes
out that's all the democrats probably
hate them too but they don't want to
lose you know they have they had people
talk about this with the vaccine a lot
the people were like vaccines i know i
know four people have had really bad
effects man it's but
and then then you talk to the people
that look at the action that was yeah
you see there was a lot of spit yeah
yeah then you look at well i want you to
catch what i'm have what i have but but
then you look at the mega data the
metadata of how many how many people
have actually taken the vaccine no side
effects you know and then you look at
how many people actually took the
vaccine and died versus people who like
most of the icu's most people dead are
not vaccinated so if you look at that
stuff so like you know you have to be
careful with people who come up with
like they
you know they they use their own
personal experience yeah to project a
larger truth
though if they're around that you know
that's all they know yeah but you gotta
look at the data you gotta look at the
data yeah but where do you even get real
data these days it's out there but i
know
everybody's got a [ __ ] story yeah
they really do everybody's got a story
fox has got their story cnn's got their
story
fox is like you know we like trump and
[ __ ] cnn's like well well biden's
better than trump you know
and that's that's well now cnn doesn't
have like uh like they can't use the
trump propaganda like that was their
ratings now it's like they're focused on
rogan
because they need somebody to point a
finger at they need somebody to give
them ratings because the ratings are dog
[ __ ] so now they're like joseph brogan
whatever he does yeah
sure exactly so interesting really
[ __ ] weird good luck with that really
like a dude who just interviews very
very you know when you go after certain
people you're gonna go after comics or
like a comic and a guy who interviews
interesting people that's who you're
going after him
dude i think he should uh
why not sue cnn for saying that
i mean you know that seems a tough one
yeah
yeah
but but it's true it's like
find somebody else to go after
[Music]
horse tv you're not a horse you're not a
cow seriously y'all stop
it well don't say y'all you know yeah
you're not a horse you're not a cow
seriously i'll stop it that's what the
fda wrote on twitter
i mean
who's running that yeah that's just
trying to get to make it young
to treat or prevent covet 19.
work for rogan
it's fine a question about that because
i don't know much about that ivermectin
or whatever yeah that
that pill is not strictly for
horses there's two it's just it's just
human version there's an animal version
i don't know i clearly didn't take the
handle about it he's not he did no
and if he
yeah yeah one thing to keep in mind
about all this [ __ ] is like when the
sars virus came out and killed a lot of
people yeah it jumped from a bat to a
civic cat to a human
um
there was uh there was an american
scientist i think it was a chinese
national or he was a chinese-american
he was an exchange student but whatever
but they said let us study we want to
study the stars of virus
this is way back this is you know let us
study the stars virus so we can figure
out that if there's another sars
outbreak the problem with that is that
the nih then grants gives you a bunch of
grants to stu has a you know is in
collusion with the wuhan lab that
studies viruses okay and it's like well
let's study this virus so it so the next
time it comes out we can treat it we're
prepared the problem with making
virologists that's that success that or
that powerful is that
that is when you get game of gain of
function research that is when you get
now you take now you got a bunch of bats
yeah you capture a bunch of bats you
give them a [ __ ] cough
and you know you shoot you and you try
to you try to make the virus more deadly
more transmissible to humans so you can
study it yeah that would be gain of
function i'm not a scientist but this is
the idea but the problem is
you got to be really [ __ ] careful
with what happens because all science
has an agenda if you're a scientist and
you were to say global warming isn't
that much of a threat just say you said
that much yeah it's not that much of a
threat
or maybe maybe uh we can innovate our
way out of this without legislating our
way out of us and here's why
you would get exactly zero dollars for
your grant you can't so what happens is
so you're a scientist you're a climate
scientist or whatever you are and you
say i want funding
i got my team i need funding now now
listen so you go you know it's not that
bad all of a sudden okay you don't need
funding now what are all the other
scientists the groups that are actually
looking to get a grant to study climate
change etc okay i'm not saying i'm not
saying climate change doesn't exist i'm
saying what happens if you're
when all the other scientists realize
that this other group of scientists
saying uh it's not that big a threat or
maybe it's not a thing whatever it is or
we have evidence that it's it's not what
we said it was
that is a threat in many ways to the
other groups of scientists that are
looking to get grants so everything is
political everything is political you
just got to look at that i'm not i don't
know the answer but it was yeah he was
explaining that i thought it was [ __ ]
something
look at the bigger picture yeah we're
already bored i just boarded up
everything it was so boring
and it wasn't your story either so it
was like
it wasn't my story i was trying to bank
off of it i was like
so if you don't believe in global
warming
i got bored i'm not even saying that but
if you don't like global warming and
then for example you're going to want
money
and then look
i was like oh my god i got a little i
got a little boy i started
might be an issue there are certain
words i'm already tired like you said to
me you know climate change i'm already
like uh are you or how about this the
worst is this
my favorite part of brian is i'm not a
scientist i know i'm like oh [ __ ] dude
this whole time i thought you were a
legit scientist you were a scientist not
just a podcast
or
or how about this but the worst is the
regurgitated story from somebody who
probably knows what they're talking
about and then you're telling us
i was trying to remember then it's like
all choppy
yeah there's nothing worse than the
story about climate change and then i
chop it up
a second hand or how about this that's
the same and i heard this my friend goes
you know
he was talking to me he goes
camping
he goes campaign finance reform i mean
that's the and i'm already asleep i'm
like holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i'm sorry i entertained that
one i'm sorry
but i just said i'm curious i thought he
had something you got to add something
you got to add somebody's got to die
something's gotta happen jim what'd you
do this weekend get me out of here
what'd you do this weekend watch this
it's gonna be good
i know you think you're gonna get get me
out of here get you out you asking what
the [ __ ] he did you went you you're so
desperate to get out of this
you know me my girl chilled oh we had
korean barbecue one night and then uh
went on a fairness that's the answer
he's like god i don't know come back
went on a food tour
i mostly just rested but my girl dispen
my girl just spent the weekend with me
boring
and then
and then my my cousin and my brother
came over we had a little birthday
dinner for her birthday
birthday brunch for my cousin's kid
then turned four
and then then went to the bowling
butterfly here in uh what is it what is
that bowling butterflies a restaurant
right where our old studios to be on
jefferson oh across the street
yeah how was it is it good it's pretty
good it's called bull and butterfly
they're known for their steaks yeah oh
it's like a steakhouse yeah oh damn it
was good yeah it's pretty good
pretty good hey there we go pretty good
would you have a [ __ ] play we had a
some sort of
was it filet mignon or a sirloin it was
a sirloin be more specific
i want to be more specific
just add it there's nothing in life i
don't want to go to that restaurant now
a nice
took us to was dope i know but you know
the name of it i don't know the name of
it yeah
or orchid kitchen
orchid kitchen i want to tell the story
but i don't want i don't want to put the
guy i'm doing it
all right
he's a good guy did you tell him to move
to l.a some people just tend to be a
little bit understated he told me to
move to l.a
he tells everybody no you're different
chappelle i felt it when he said it
you're different i don't tell anyone to
do stand-up i've told exactly two people
in my life to do stand-up mm-hmm more
more
i'm sitting here believing that you
didn't know you said dude
funny kid that'd be three that's
different though i don't know i know
that's what's weird but but i but i i
don't tell anybody to stand up
even you remember when you said i was
just pretend i was like yeah oh you know
it wasn't that i didn't think i just
it's just such a long road yeah um
but uh i felt you were being honest with
you i was i said come to l.a you could
that that guy is not ready for like he
would get did you tell him that
no but i tried to kind of ask him to set
i was like what are your goals
buffalo wing place in buffalo yeah
that's a good market yeah yeah
open up a buffalo wing thanks for doing
nothing dude open up a food 70 buffalo
something like shots buffalo or
something like that
no no they'll drink it you know what i
mean the one thing about cocoa
buffalo
you know what one thing i think we all
realize is we love restaurants during
this pandemic and all this stuff we
realize how much we depend on
restaurants you know who's giving back
to restaurants grubhub grubhub is
launching their new
campaign we serve restaurants grubhub
loves restaurants like we love
restaurants from the food to the passion
termination of the people behind them
they know that restaurants reputations
matter and they'll be damned if that
reputation suffers because of them all
right because good food deserves good
service delivered fast fresh exactly how
the restaurants intend it to be all
right i love restaurants and that's why
i use grubhub so grubhub works hard to
serve the restaurants and they want the
restaurant's food to come exactly how
they mean for it to come maybe you're a
gamer maybe you're a podcaster maybe
you're a family dude maybe you're a
stay-at-home dad you don't have time to
cook and do all this stuff grubhub got
you covered man and today they're
they're getting together panera today
grubhub's doing a little extra surf
panera get a free delivery perk on your
first order from panera panera bread
they got great stuff sandwiches whatever
you want man sounds tasty cool you can
uh get free delivery on your order from
panera 15 or more order through the
grubhub app or online grubhub we serve
restaurants next week september 24th and
25th i'm in san antonio texas texas bud
light event center it's going down one
show friday one show saturday biggest
shows ever for your boy and i'm bringing
a crew with me man i got derek poston
that's right derek poston's back we got
david lucas and chappelle backflip lacey
and myself will all be in san antonio
texas on the 24th 25th one show friday
one show saturday get your tickets right
now and then denver colorado comedy
works september 30th through october 2nd
that's the con works downtown denver
mama i'm coming home then las vegas
nevada is october 7th through the 9th
break california's october 15th through
the 17th get your tickets at f-a-t-k-z
com
he said wow
classic all right have you seen this
officer that looks just like the rock
yeah from alabama i have not this is
actually the police officer right here
holy [ __ ] no it's not yes it is that's
him there's no way that's the cop eric
fields but this is just the perfect
angle and everything because the other
features don't look so much like as much
yeah but this one looks just like the
rock that's crazy is there another
picture yeah yeah he's big
big dude tj watts dad's driving the car
he's a younger version
shave that mustache
got a skin tight and then didn't the
wrong reach out then like he wants to
get drinks with him or something like
that i didn't see that part
that's him there different angle here
you can see you can see how he kind of
looks like him but not really
not really right there i think the only
thing him and the rock have in common
they're both on steroids
yeah this guy's definitely huge for sure
dude oh yeah that dude's all netty i
don't know guys he's he might be on that
that's the rock there yeah i love how
everybody wants to take pictures with
him
yeah i bet he's a [ __ ] yeah in
alabama that's that's amazing
god he's pretty damn close yeah he kind
of like went to once the but that one on
the truck you look excited yeah but he's
also tall and big
he's a big dude
what would you say
the rock is what kind of gear is he
running i name a steroid is that true
what do you think dude yeah i think
i thought you just have to like narrow
down to one no i don't think i don't
know much about the whole gamut trouble
and all that tremble
and a ball i don't know anavar
i guess he's either way it works his ass
could be that shredded 53
what did you say you want an nfr no i
don't know anova i don't want nothing
you can't even handle a [ __ ] sprout
yeah my [ __ ] teeth are chattering
still
would it be weird if i said can i get a
decaf
no people do it all the time it makes no
sense to me but people do it all the
time well i like the taste there you go
there's still caffeine and decaf though
get a nice green tea those are nice
this is really can drink
it truly was nice right how's your nest
it's exactly the same it is yeah and
i've shout out to like the t-fat k army
they a ton of them message me different
things to do chiropractor
i mean i'm i don't really trust going to
chiropractor for this i want to get an
mri that's what i want i want to get an
mri
yeah get an mri
and don't wrestle without warming up
yeah
ever again i know i know don't wrestle
them specifically not the short kings
never again kings so this is vin diesel
all right jack shirtless on a luxury
yacht getting it
oh
i would never know i would have never
known because he always wears you know
tank top yeah so his arms are still buff
looking but i guess he's just a little
bit that's me
very similar
yeah that's what will happen just tell
me if you're not careful as you get
older
no you're still buff though i still got
a chance i need something i'm pretty
sure 50 clowned on him too did he yeah
damn that's awesome 50 cents all over
the place now
that's a big that's a lot of fun yeah
but that picture is almost damn right
well his body is he looks like [ __ ] man
it looks fat oh my gosh yeah dude yeah
like he's not a yacht you know didn't
give a [ __ ] i'll lose it in a heartbeat
though yeah you could get ready for fast
and fish 17
yeah how many are there they have nine
right now they have nine yeah they're
planning for 10 x or whatever oh [ __ ]
it's booming right it makes money i
don't know how but it makes money i mean
people with a lot of i mean people
people
people
used to be so good and he owns like
fifty percent of it he makes so much
money off those
and the director is asian
oh wow yeah
doesn't talk to his own mission
impossible
ooh i would doubt it no i thought he was
justin lynn it's been around forever he
might though
all right so this is theo posting
him fishing this is actually pretty good
he literally caught it after baiting
yeah i'll show you this first
but there's something funny about what
theo does here
we caught our bait right here these are
minnows that we caught with a net
in the re in the in the creek out here
and we save them here in this minnow
bucket
and then
i want to take this little bag baby and
put it right in the seam right there
where that water is coming off of this
river this little creek
catches one right away yeah but look how
he does the reel too you know a fish you
had a fish a spinning rod right yeah
look
[Laughter]
that'd be fun to swim in that's a super
nice creek or river where is that i
don't know nashville in nashville damn
watch it oh bam here we go
but he's he's oh damn he's holding it
upside down the reel
oh
these are
all natural fish
no preservatives
nothing
look at that oh yeah that's a decent
[Applause]
let's go boy i'm upstairs look he got
that little one on the uber like he's
driving uber
uber xl that little one trying to see
your ride baby
you got to be hungry if you you bite you
don't even eat the food
you just get fork only
oh he's so [ __ ] funny
he's [ __ ] organic it's four goals
funniest human beings of all time
um
yeah i wouldn't know that really yeah
you would if it's in your hand you're
not going to do that yeah you're doing
it this way that's so that's from
wrestler dad 247. that tactic it's
hilarious oh
this one i know a bunch of people tagged
as well i guess oh
it's supposed to be pretty
well big boy why didn't now that makes
me nervous why do you like it he's like
trying to get your head hands free one
oh oh
[Music]
god those shots were working
look at the impact why would he let go i
don't know i think he's not trying to
don't like that
yeah yeah look at the rear shock
right on the old all that ass i know
that's gonna leave underwear just
hanging out
red [ __ ] mark
and this one as well for that
yellowstone prequel they're having billy
bob thornton joined holy oh [ __ ]
god that's going gonna be good started
watching it
uh do you like it that's great right
don't say anything damn pretty cool man
that's not i just gotta get past the
first episode yeah yeah you get two
billion
yeah he looks like he's had his face
tightened a little bit he looks good he
always looks a little different
yeah looks like he's uh had some stuff
good [ __ ] actor
one of the best angelina jolie were like
wearing each other's blood around him i
was working with him they did what they
were like vials of blood oh yeah
i was i worked with him he was he's a
great guy man yeah great guy
really really cool
oh for uh he's sober now was it bad
santa yep
is he sober now mine's in bed sounds
like i'm gonna look at him look at her
billy bob tattoo
with a dragon dude imagine convincing
angelina jolie to get a billy bob she's
had two she's she was so beyonce
you know those lips are real by the way
or her dad's john voight right yes
she she's so special she went from that
to [ __ ] brad pitt dude yeah well when
you're when you're angelina jolie you
can you can have vladimir putin or
anybody else you want me yeah
she's such a
she's so talented she was super hot
yeah she's perfect i remember super
talented i met her before she was famous
on the set of oz when she was just she
showed up she was dating chuck sedo i
remember looking she was dating chuck
zeta
or at least she
came to meet him left on his motorcycle
oh wow jumped on the back
he wrote away
so you know
but uh that's chuck zedo yeah oh there
you go he was in sons of anarchy too
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
he had to roll in there yeah
it's kind of his life
yeah
but uh
did he die his hair she was so beautiful
just a little bit
yeah
all right so we we had this on below the
belt but i wanted to get your guys's
take as well this transgender fighter
you gotta make a lot before and after oh
yeah so let me let me paint it for brian
was a male
transition to female fought another real
female inside a steel cage i want you to
see the before picture of what she
looked like okay chin dude
that's jake's talking about herself jake
there you go
crazy huh okay now hold on
i gotta just take a second here she was
also an army ranger that's what he found
out i didn't i had no idea what is that
army ranger so you're talking about that
guy talking about very strong
can take a lot of punishment if you're a
ranger that's no joke
and uh and and they're letting you
they're letting that that person fight
women
advantages that person fight biological
women but she should be able to fight
but other transgender or men that's
right
but not a normal little female girl like
that ain't right
it's just the the the same bravest child
to transition then live her dream of
beating up women that's what jake's i
mean
i don't know i think it's kind of
appropriate isn't it i i don't know
that's him on the uh on the left yeah
that other picture that that's jake
shields on the left dude oh okay is he
retired or he's just hasn't fought he's
retired he does jiu-jitsu oh he tweeted
about this great dude he's a great team
beautiful yeah
transgender mma fighter who used to be
in us army special forces
yeah you're so so i mean it'd be tough
for a dude to beat her up i agree an
army ranger you know the special forces
mental capacity that that girl has
since and the advantages he has over
some girl who's where they probably want
to know two and o also bone structure
also like well first look on the left
there he'd be everybody in this room
including me that's right
that's right that's a rough [ __ ]
yeah so this is her statement because
she's getting a lot of you know people
reacting to this what'd she say uh good
morning friends supporters and others
i'm getting a lot of variation in the
same nasty message call me a cheater
like i didn't just
get beat on on for a round and a half
you all need to show some respect and
taking certain trolling somewhere else
she almost finished me more than once on
you might just be a bad fighter on
scorecard she definitely won the first
round this is the only post i'll make
about this transphobes are just making
me my block and stronger
it's not being transphobe either it's
just it's not about being a translator
yeah it's just
about
dude i'm all i support transgender and
all that stuff
they should be able to compete in
olympics in mma and boxing but not
against
that's where it gets tricky yeah that's
where it gets little teachers it's not
tricky it's just like that it's not it's
not fair i know and a lot of instances
is not fair for sure so so just to me
this is dangerous i think this is
dangerous for for other women i i don't
know i mean
and it has nothing to do with being a
transphobic i don't if you want to be
transgender then it's kind of actually
cool that this hyper male felt like a
woman did this that's fine yeah do that
okay but fighting other women
come on that girl isn't such a
disadvantage but not only that as you
know if if that woman is fighting him
and taking taking major damage it can
also shorten her career
it sounds like she got her ass whooped
for a little bit and then she's saying
that she's who's the girl she fought
this girl right here oh i'll show you oh
yeah it's a
i mean i i'm surprised i didn't know
that the commission allowed it so
i don't know
that girl fought a [ __ ] special
forces transgender girl yeah so that
goes on a record now i mean and and when
when she was in special forces was
jacked to the gills right is there any
videos of the fight anyway
um i'm sure on youtube yeah
let's let's let's look it up
if you type in that wanna mclaughlin
transgender girl's name you're gonna
find it there you go fight
full fight
how long
30 minutes back here on combat global
with keep playing with that head down
which is very very damn that girl's
and she has taken a lot of estrogen
that's a difficult thing for us so
interesting it's amazing what technology
can do right
yeah i'm still frustrating it blows my
mind every time i think transition now
that i'm watching this
now that i'm watching this
i might start i mean
not looking like the stronger fighter
and taking a ton of punishment coming in
getting picked up it's just her bones
are denser her but her bone structure
her ligaments are stronger
the training that she's gone through in
the special reaction reaction time too
for men is a little bit better than the
women their eyes
we're actually about 25 minutes from
september 11th
that's it but she finishes the other
girl with a choke
i don't know i mean
here we are right here yeah
all right finished
okay
anyways
interesting both clearly new to the
sport
seems like it yeah
that's dicey right it's dicey
they should definitely be able to
compete and live their dreams it's just
tough when they're going against
biological women it'd be great if there
was a transgender
league
is there is there a woman that
transitioned into a man that i don't
think it's ever been done
what's that a woman has transmissions to
a man i don't think that's ever been in
fights
do you know that it's because
you know what would happen
you know what would happen the the map
they would never get commissioned if a
female want to transition to a boy and
fight in the ufc no commission would
ever grant that
that's right but then we're cool
with a man transitioning to a woman be
like well
so you know it was kind of
exceedingly rare until all this trans
movement happened it was exceedingly
rare for a a woman to transition into a
man he was almost always a man woman if
you look at the literature behind it and
then and then what's interesting is that
now that it's become such a thing
there are some places where thirty
percent of the girls in certain
classrooms identify as trans now it's
like this social contagion it's probably
not probably not that high but the good
thing is with science and technology
stuff they can finally come out and
there's at least some support back in
the
day
yeah yeah yeah it was hell for everyone
what else you got jen this is a good
news one uh justin wren your guys's
friend
our friend
he i guess for the fight for the
forgotten
he
found some guy that was like that worked
in
uh wall street
then covet happened lost his job lost
his i guess his girl whatever and then
he got robbed on the subway got done
yeah on the same day
during that time yeah and then someone
with a bat like seven seven people even
though they took his money and
everything they hit him in the head or
face worst day ever like three times and
he lost nine teeth holy [ __ ]
yeah new york yeah subway i think new
york jesus christ or wall street yes new
york oh yeah wall street and so justin
ran and i guess the fight fight for the
forgotten they were able to get all his
brand new teeth
you can see him like reacting here
expensive too
oh yeah i remember hearing the crisis
and he told me the day before the day i
met you
he was hired by dr frank dave frank at
walden dentistry
he said keep your eyes your ears open
for somebody why are all their shirts
off
they're probably working out in the park
what a great so let me show you what it
looks like look at that
that's what happened yeah he was on on
drugs and stuff is that what happened i
think he might have fallen down that
path yeah because everything was falling
apart
chin
keep it cool man you're cool
he looks great now yeah he looks great
he looks wonderful hold on
you know man
what you could be i didn't do anything
[ __ ] compassionate i'm super i don't
know because you know what i see every
time you do this is what he does he goes
like this
well i wasn't [ __ ] ready dude fingers
pointed are you going
oh well the story was the guy lost his
job got hit in the face with the batman
god that's terrible and then you bring
him up and maybe not
you could have been like dude he also
did some drugs his teeth are all [ __ ]
up yeah there was it was tough times man
there's tough times who knows what the
toughest times yeah and those teeth
may not have come out from a bat they
may have come out from meth
maybe a little bit of both is this your
opener in buffalo or
now listen up that
i don't want to say that go to the next
picture jim why not yeah i think the
next one shows how good of a person
justin wren dude he's the best so what
this is when he was on wall street and
stuff yeah yeah so that was before so
his teeth are even better now
damn you walked to brooklyn called quit
to jump off yeah yeah that's tough oh
[ __ ] he got
oh here's why their shirts off uh
tomorrow we fly to manhattan tuesday
together we do the same walk to brooklyn
bridge 101 blocks that's not close
instead of feeling hopeless i know it
would be hope filled instead of him
listening to a podcast of me talking joe
rogan we'd probably be talking together
instead of him to sign against suicide
because of my story where we re re-write
our stories together we're going to
speak about life life we lived
a life well that's amazing
wow
so he was suicidal yeah there you go
that's great man that's so cool justin
redden's just uh
he's an angel
before anybody here yep when he sees
those teeth he didn't go oh wow and then
he can vouch for me and get me in yeah
well
that's so cool man oh that poor guy oh
[ __ ]
that's pretty ambitious i love it
so he's looking at the picture of what
his teeth actually look like the
suspense he's looking at that picture we
saw yeah
the before and after
damn
wait so that that's the mock-up all
right that's what no that's what they
did right there i think they already did
it but he hasn't seen it in the mirror
yet or something like that
yeah
no this is like the reveal for him yeah
yeah
yeah that's a revo
wow get this out of here and only look
at the eyes
the eyes tell whether or not it's an
awesome smile
when you're confident with your smile
look at your eyes
yeah wow the eyes are even different yep
what brian what are you
it's like a great white shark guy like
that's like he's like dead behind no i'm
i'm i'm not even trying to be funny it's
like he's right when you're doing drugs
man your eyes die too
your eyes stuck to you know what i'm
saying like you they're just checked out
and
then on the right and clearly got his
[ __ ] together and look out
is the eyes of the window to your
shoulder
that's my time
it's also like better lighting better
portrait earlier
everybody in this room is a piece of
[ __ ]
none of us do anything for anyone
and then you got justin yeah easy doing
this stuff oh dude he's such a good
person yeah yeah brandon's looking at
pictures going oh
you do this well i thought
you ever know if brendan is judging the
[ __ ] out of you he'll be doing this with
his
like silence like you know how like like
p like in the if at least even
elizabethan times should be like the
people with starfish their chests like
oh my brennan actually does a version of
that but he goes
when he does this yeah well i wasn't
ready i thought he got hit in the face
with a bat and i thought they're going
to show that yes you
[Music]
you said he got hit three times with a
bat and i think you made that story
that story was not in there chin where
did you leave that it is it is not on
that poster was it
hold on yeah
the only thing is said he got fell into
some drugs and at this point in time i
want
yeah here it goes
he has lost the level he relapsed on
drugs
he ended up homeless he was robbed and
assaulted in subway station
he gave his money to the gang of seven
people then he saw since swan the guy
with the baseball bat they beat him
anyways at no point does it oh here we
go yeah it says i've seen the report
chris was in the icu for a while he said
three to four swings to his head face
and mouth with a metal belt
metal bat sounded like a t-ball ball
ping [ __ ] he had tbi his mother was told
by the doctors we don't think he's going
to make it he lost nine teeth that day
with many others broken and damaged
yeah terrible but i think it's a
combination of the drugs like the meth
engine hitting the face with the back
they kind of don't talk about that well
yeah they don't wanna yeah yeah yeah so
when you're that down he had some very
great i mean we're nitpicking here look
at him look at him now he's good justin
is a good guy man he's good he's the
best way to go
but his face is justin wren looks very
thin too he lost a lot of weight yeah he
looks like he's such a good person man
good for him you trained with him right
oh yeah long time was he a was he a
pedigreed wrestler yeah
oh wow
but then he had issues uh oh yeah drugs
yeah oh big time yeah yeah
he's doing that
yeah he's he talks about his surprise
he's so good he's doing the lord's work
yeah
all right here's some of cat's
chin i mean that's great chin did not
alert us to that picture did he
he didn't he didn't do it for the navy
seal or the army ranger either he's like
yeah look i'm like dude
that army ranger yeah we need real
reactions yeah yeah i like that
i like that
all right so this is uh
let's see
oh bunch of dookie came out oh no fans
recording a video of a pipe rupture
during the washington versus chargers
football game oh that's a problem bad
enough
you want to see me get screamish
i bet that's whoever got that first hit
man i know they they're probably what
yeah let's just see brown [ __ ] dude i
i'm so squeamish to that [ __ ]
literally
i will be i would be so far away from
that [ __ ] dude
that's all the the
wastes oh my god blowing out i can't
handle that
[ __ ] people think of football oh my god
oh
that's that's [ __ ] from everywhere yeah
that's gross that's deep that's the [ __ ]
of many of many states people too baby
yes
many many counties
you can catch anything from anywhere
whoa no verdict split verdict oh maybe
it's just water but it was all dirty
looking it was all
brown yeah that was piss yeah i'm not
taking chances yeah i'm not buying this
[ __ ] yeah fresh water wow most felt
it was just
yeah oh one fedex veteran you see that
cat that fell there i love the college
kids that grab it and hold them up like
simba and he's like he's just freaking
out
yeah man they're all
holding him he's just freaking my
girlfriend and i she we rescued a cat
and she picked it up and wouldn't let it
go that thing tore her up on i'm talking
about her face and her hands and she's
it's when i kind of fell a little bit in
love with her she wouldn't let it go she
[ __ ] just took it and smiled through
the whole thing she's bleeding
everywhere for real and she the guy we
get in touch with the [ __ ] guy
because she's trying to read the tag guy
pulls up in a prius doesn't even thank
us he goes yeah he wanders
well my girl's got cast scratch fever
now you [ __ ] yeah but there was just
a cat walking around yes and we thought
it was lost i know it's a cat
it's a [ __ ] i'm with the guy like hey
[ __ ] face
i would be too you're lucky it wasn't
meaner i'd be like hey it shredded her
up like i when you see what a little
captain a lot of him yeah he probably
probably is an outside cat yeah man [ __ ]
out of her hey but you know what
i know he said he said this is what i
fell in love with we were like
she didn't put it we're trying to
[Applause]
but how stupid is that yeah a little bit
stupid how about this
yesterday he's all that's the day yes i
fell in love yep i hear that i'm like
red flag
yesterday i [ __ ] go to costco buy
myself a large screen tv
get out to the truck and it doesn't fit
in the back of the of my girl's suv
won't fit in the back you know you put
the seats in a smaller suv so it doesn't
fit through the hole oh yeah yeah can't
fit in yeah so now now i'm i'm all i'm
i'm pissed and i'm shouting at the wind
and she's like stop doing that it's not
you're making a scene i'm like [ __ ] this
and i go and i'm not and i just can't
take it back
i can't take it back and i'm just
sitting in the in the parking lot and i
just and i'm like i'm gonna just sit
here
maybe for two hours i don't know let me
let me just go through this real quick
you bought this giant tv yeah nobody
measured sure didn't sure sure did yeah
sure didn't that was what the fight was
about i go should we measure she's like
no that'll fit
get it out there and now i'm mad at her
okay i'd be pissed too yeah yeah now i'm
mad at her
a little fight goes on you know those
fights she's like she gets in she's like
[ __ ] this and now i'm just standing
there she goes just return it i go i'm
not gonna return i'm just gonna sit now
does she still have scratches from the
couch she does not
i'm glad you asked yeah that was that's
a long time okay yeah long time ago very
marked up though very bad scar it was a
jaguar
so um
a [ __ ] couple this woman goes comes
by and goes sorry we were watching you
guys i mean this i can just i was
laughing because this would this is the
kind of fight he and i have do you we
have a truck do you want us to take that
out that's nice
i was like yeah i would love that that's
so nice just follow us back to our house
let's put the groceries in put the thing
in there blah blah blah follow them back
and then and then did they drive off
their tv they i thought they were going
to
i was like just load it up and then text
that just let me either
take off and that's that's what you that
is a good scam nope they were awesome
as we're pulling away from their house
to go to miles they uh wait why did you
go to their house because they didn't
drop all their groceries they bought ice
cream and drop off their ice cream they
were living in the same area and then
there is an enormous woman
covered in blood
lying on the sidewalk on her back are
you running now no i swear to god she's
covered in blood why don't you start
with this she's enormous
and
now the good samaritans who are the good
samaritans who said we'll take your tv
she jumps out now to help the woman
so i'm like oh why was she covering
blood shaver cat she she was walking her
dogs i guess she has fainting spells she
was giant and she she had a she hadn't
when i say she had a face
yep
and she was just all covered in blood
and the eventful day of time i know and
then her i guess her husband had gone
back to get the car because she was
walking the dog she lived in the
neighborhood and other people are there
and
what do you do in that situation what do
you do i'll tell you what i did with the
lady all covered up yeah called the
ambulance you call the ambulance yes you
let them because there's so many factors
going on with it yep we had the same
thing
you know what i did no you know what i
was just kidding i'm really helpful i go
i go um just don't move i go stay there
and then to make her feel better like i
do so i was like happened to me happened
to me
that helps everybody looks at me and
they go
happen to me same thing i felt and i
thought i was gonna die you're gonna be
totally fine so nobody called anybody no
they did they call it somebody oh
all things you could have said it was so
well no she said i'm fine i had this is
not uncommon for me i have fainting
spells oh wow she'll be walking around
yeah she's a big an enormous woman no
your guy was a stroke wait what were we
gonna say that guy had a stroke in
kentucky yeah oh really yeah we're just
i'm like that guy's moving where he was
like oh no no that's just false you mean
at the show no oh we're driving back
from lunch to our airbnb we saw him walk
in the neighborhood and just fell down
and what'd you do called the cop
ambulance and then i was he was like i
don't need an ambulance i just uh just
get me right back to the house and then
we're trying to get him in the car but
he couldn't bend his leg and it was it
was impossible you're a large man no
normal dude but he just you know the way
he was all [ __ ] up he couldn't bend
his arm or legs so we were trying to
figure out like a puzzle piece how to
get in the car and then we had a smaller
car so
he was having a heart attack or it was a
stroke you had a stroke yeah so then i
was like dude i'm gonna call the cops
then we called the cops and that he was
like no i don't want them like dude
you're bleeding you had a [ __ ] stroke
the cops are coming dude then we don't
want to waste their time on your shop
we're not here we can't have that yeah
then the ambulance came and they they
got them situated
that's the thing too because for me
selfishly i was like now my friend is a
good samaritan's got my tv in the truck
i want to get home it's good it's an
all-day project yeah and i'm like we
gotta i was busy with that guy for like
four hours sitting there that's a long
time it took all the time not to go
straight to the shows the nightmare yeah
but you know but you got to do it you
can't just be like i gotta catch you
just leave it because i'm lazy yeah you
know i don't have time for this you'll
be all right walk it off
limp it off
can i tell you a quick story yeah uh so
what i was doing about when i was a
balancer for two years
my friend's boyfriend was in the club he
got completely wasted
and then he was passed out on the
sidewalk
outside the club outside the club they
dragged him out security dragged him out
so i was like are you guys gonna call
9-1-1 they're like no because if we call
9-1-1 it's on us like the payment or
something like for the ambulance oh
something like that
so i was like i feel like he we should
call 9-1-1 he's not even responding he's
so then out like filming at the mouth he
was just kind of like
barely breathing and just like oh yeah
that's true
so i called his girlfriend my friend and
i was like
they're not going to call 911. do you
want me to call 911. i feel like i have
to call 9-1-1 yeah she goes yeah call it
so i finally called 9-1-1 so it's on me
now because i'm the one that called they
picked him up and apparently from what
she said that he would have died that
day
yeah yeah what was going on
i don't know respiratory system heavier
guy no no he's just good looking tall
the mouth
you touch his mouth i'm trying to get
all the details
no mouth enough but i did like stay by
and make sure that i'm what's going on
i'm wearing pants whispering
black pants and that guy had when i
guess i have a stroke i looked at jay
he's gonna need mouth-to-mouth and you
have to do it jacob's you know jay's
like [ __ ] off
oh dude just hold his nose like a baby
but he's blowing his nose
apparently you're supposed to just push
on his chest or something i don't know
dude we'll figure it out and if you if
you've done cpr training that means
you're reliable right yeah no if you
don't know it that's what i heard no
that's a myth i took it like i don't
think they said that years ago yeah you
can you can absolutely you should
absolutely try to save something okay so
that cat thing you guys are talking
about hilarious let's see him up like
simba
it's so crazy look how far
so cat's dangling kitty
and they're holding the american flag
right there
look how scared everybody is yeah so is
that you know that guy would be fine if
he landed right there in the flag yeah
they hold him up like simba and he
scratches the piss out
look at the cat he's all [ __ ] bro
the crowd the crap hey also crowd it's a
cat
oh oh they broke his fault we got him
tear this guy to pieces
oh
kitty that is so funny [ __ ] terrified
i guess they broke it oh there is
scratch the piss out of this guy he's
like ah
he's scratching everybody
you gotta know cats dude [ __ ] cats i
hate cats you're not a cat guy [ __ ] i
like holding them i don't mind them i
don't like them i don't trust people you
know
you know you can leave a cat and they do
not care yeah like if you had a cat i
know that take your cat take to my house
he wouldn't give a [ __ ] you tame them
you can't domesticate them they don't
care they have owners they don't care
they have the same mind as well but i
don't hate them no you give them no i
don't want one i don't hate i'm not
gonna go around killing them but i don't
well isn't that the thing where they
have a they have a toxin they think that
they think that cats
have a certain carry a certain toxin
that can actually
cause you to go crazy later on in your
life have you heard about that rogan had
a thing about it on on the podcast i've
never heard of that yeah but another
reason i'd buy it so so you remember
they used to say she's an old lady with
her cats oh crazy lady with a cat yeah
yeah yeah
that can be correlated oh because it's a
deep cut and i don't buy it but yeah no
there there it is yeah toxoplasma it's a
parasite that invades the brains of mice
and organs of cats it's a person
invasive brains of mice resulting in
disease called toxoplasmosis
the parasite can also
so cat [ __ ] makes you crazy they think
so yeah don't eat cat [ __ ] you know well
just really i don't think they're
consuming i think it's just the fumes of
it being in the litter box in a house
yeah well they also actually they also
the litter box have a has a scent oh
yeah but the other question was it could
have like some kids who had brain tumors
and owned cats there was a correlation
that they were they were doing about
that too
so
crazy it's cat lady stereotypes oh yeah
brian what if that's like a common thing
i don't know yeah i don't know right
do you guys know who tyler herrera is
yeah dude
i don't super sudden yeah i've never
heard of him obviously he's the white
boy from miami his man played great he's
about to have a kid
really yeah he was the one who the
instagram girl uh bar stool had her on
there she was reaching out to him and
then she slammed his dms then like after
the game he posted like her ass in his
hotel room they're about to have a kid
oh really mm-hmm wow oh that's
that yeah well [ __ ] yeah because she's
from arizona she used to cheer oh so
they ended up hooking up i mean getting
married or whatever no i don't think
they're not but having a kid
yeah they end up having sex yeah but
been a child though but yeah i don't
think well i don't think it was planned
you know yeah oh
wow wow what would be upset about it
yeah you do a lot worse than that yeah
oh i remember now yeah she's that's her
she's not delicious
she's phenomenal yeah she used to be a
cheerleader back in arizona christ yeah
she's ridiculous i mean good for him
yeah well now they have a kid so yeah
good i guess a girl saw him and got so
excited she crashed her car holy [ __ ]
he's not that big
[Applause]
there's a song
oh no that's so dangerous so she left
your card again autograph running
jesus yeah kind of just like roll it
into the building
yeah it wasn't that bad his name is
harrow hero hero hero yeah wow that's
cool you know the origin of hero hero
no i don't know if you do you have a lot
of you know
there's a lot of knowledge on [ __ ] the
guy's last name yeah yeah i bet you it's
greek i bet you see there he goes look
at he's got something for it i bet you
that one man it comes from the
commitment
but he probably does yeah no he's
getting he just gave us he's not a
scientist but he gave us information
about global warming i bet you it's
either roman or it's it's a greek it's a
greek derivative something no h-e-r-o
bubba it was two r's
for hero yes hero greek name spanish
habitational name from no no it's called
no i'm saying what i'm saying is the
we're really looking at this
road i didn't want to go down no i was
saying h-e-r-o oh you're saying well his
name is spelled h you're asking about
his name particularly okay i thought oh
there you go here's
ancient greek meaning hero
all right
hero is a greek word then
i was right there you go see well no
hero is his last name is h-e-r-r-o does
it give a name of ancient greek origin
there you go there you go i was right he
was right everybody's right he's writing
this hero
of course it's greek origin
you don't know what you just bullshitted
to no i mean
why i mean you know it's hiro who's this
chris hemsworth yeah but when you see
that just a
that frame of it his arm looks
ridiculous in person
i mean his arms look at his arms never
box but he's [ __ ] strong as [ __ ] big
very big no i've seen a box dude he can
move yeah yeah he can hit yeah i think
you start incorporating more of that
that's how i get rid of this good
bossing more of those uh no there's
[ __ ]
no no there's a picture of him and his
dad and his dad looks just like him
hold on a second
old pictures right here
oh [ __ ]
what is he swedish or something or
australian
oh by way of sweden
hemsworth
is that swedish please don't ask me
sorry
save it for your podcast you know
that's that was so boring to you
what are the origins of
[Music]
campaign finance reform at the end of
the day
before we do this i did want to bring up
one
one documentary i watched over the
weekend that i thought brian and you
would like which one it's called crime
it's a hockey doctor the hockey would
they get with the mafia yep uh oh yeah i
saw a little there's
talking about they're based on that
whole like the sopranos is based on them
oh interesting because the dad is mafia
james is the minor league hockey team
gives it to his 18 year old son who's 18
yeah 17 out of 17 and just starts
running the hockey team and then so yeah
i watched the documentary hockey team
yeah it was it was a uhl team it wasn't
pro but they had mike rupp who won the
pro like when they had mike rep come on
he had just won a stanley cup with the
new jersey devils half an hour down the
road and he was playing for them
everyone on the team uh who was on the
team their family was on payroll for a
no-show job fantastic they were like
even his son like you know how in the
sopranos the kid's name is aj
same with that kid a.j guantana it was
literally based off him he had a trash
empire what's the what's the the dad's
from what mafia do we know
italian italian yeah yeah so wait so so
he's the dad's origins last name galante
uh probably i'd say sicilian doesn't
matter wait so so
well his kid also loved hockey so much
and he loved it so use it as a way so
imagine
operating a hockey team at 17. he was
like
either no he wasn't bad yeah he was
crazy
he could play hockey then he had an
injury
and um then he couldn't play more that's
why his dad bought it but the kid was
making the right moves for this team to
be successful which is insane
they get busted in the end and go to
prison
yeah yeah well he's out now usually if
he's on netflix yeah yeah and then now
now the guy is a boxing promoter of
course and he owns a gym up in densburg
so when i go home for thanksgiving 100
going yeah it's a t-shirt it's an hour
away from my house i'm going 100
yeah oh wow because i grew up on canada
it's got a lot of a lot of funny
business going on a lot of tough italian
dudes yeah
my friend i don't know how true this is
because it's just if it's true he told
me that because he's from dansbury he's
like he told me his dad coached the kid
in high school and he's like i grew up
going to the games but that's fair i
don't know with them i mean it's just
like dude that's a crazy story though
the doc's supposed to be really good
they had bret uh gretzky's brother
one like uh one of the gretzkys on the
team they two of the kids who play on
played on the team
live two houses down for me back in
rhode island were they a good team yes
they were good they were the i think it
was like the first day yeah the first
day usually like the owners never call
the players before a game
20 minutes before the game i think it
was the owner the father called one of
the players like right when the puck
drops you're dropping the gloves you got
to fight
fought the first game the owner was
caught punching someone in the face like
in the game like it was just a [ __ ] show
that sounds funny there was that bald
guy who was like you're gonna play by my
rules right that little dude but yeah
but spoiler alert
every time like he got called in like
they made him seem like the biggest
[ __ ] like everyone didn't like him
the end the fbi calls him in and asked
him all these questions like i don't
know what you're talking about james
galante is one of the nicest human
beings the most loving people didn't
ride on
him nope wow and then there was a
equipment the equipment manager was my
favorite person in the entire
documentary i was telling chin earlier
whenever they would have a home game the
when the away team would come he would
just leave in like one towel he would
hide the goalies pads hide everything
like i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on i i don't know
[ __ ] i gotta watch it it's interesting
it was hurt it's good i was on the edge
of my seat
back then before cameras were everywhere
the mafia had real power before cameras
were everywhere i remember connecticut
in the summer times even in greenwich
connecticut and that's you
it was very easy to get the [ __ ] out of
you by giant italian dudes new one is
bad now it's [ __ ] man yeah yeah oh my
god yeah my friends go to quinny pack
it's really bad
right up your alley dude oh yeah yeah
that's why i loved it so much uh
all right that's it kids uh
september 24th 25th that's not this
weekend but the following weekend one
show friday one show saturday bud light
event center big shows for your boy one
show friday one show saturday i got
frickin derek poston david lucas
chappelle lacy and myself will be there
both friday and saturday shows then
september 30th october 2nd denver
colorado mom i'm coming home yes you can
have tickets october 7th through the 9th
las vegas nevada that's at the new wise
guys comedy club in las vegas nevada
then break california's october 15th to
17th tickets at f a t k z or
thickboy.com
uh come see me in denver september 23rd
24th 25th at comedy works
maybe my favorite club october 14th 15th
no no actually then what am i doing
denver is september 23rd 25th through
25th and september 30th october 2nd i'm
in chicago illinois at the schomburg
loose terms yes i'm at the schomburg
improv this time outside yes yes sir so
denver and chicago at the end of this
month let's go far out of chicago
october 7th through the night tampa
florida side splitters october 28th
through the 30th uh dc comedy loft in
washington dc you look like you're
telling ghost stories i know i don't
know who it's a good point you gave him
that picture that's a good pick
i do like my son
yeah i like it it's a good pick i like
that big okay all right well if you guys
like it all right kids that's it love
you man